la vaccination obligatoire examiné au
sénat aujourd'hui on en débat ce matin
avec gilbert roger sénateurs du parti
socialiste de la seine saint denis et
alain houpert sénateur les républicains
de la côte d'or
[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux bon ok merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur arte france pour ce débat
dans un article unique et les
parlementaires socialistes proposent de
modifier l'article du code de la santé
publique pour ajouter cette vaccination
contre le virus à la liste des onze
vaccins qui sont obligatoires
actuellement je vous propose de regarder
l'exposé des motifs des sénateurs pour
en débattre juste après
la vaccination obligatoire est le seul
chemin à ce jour pour sortir d'une
politique de sécurité sanitaire et
entrer enfin dans une politique de santé
publique clairement assumée elle est la
manifestation de la primauté de
l'intérêt général sur les tentations
individualiste de la clarté face à
l'obligation masquer que représente le
pass and i ter de l'égalité face au
chacun pour soi de la solidarité face à
l'égoïsme le choix du gouvernement a été
un choix par défaut et de défaut ce qui
le désengageait de ses responsabilités
gilbert roger vous êtes vous-même
socialistes avaient voué était de ceux
qui ont proposé cette ce projet de loi
sur bien sûr parce que nous étions tout
à fait réserver pour pas dire même
opposé au pass sanitaire qui désormais
tri nos concitoyens à l'entrée d'une
terrasse à l'entrée d'un bar restaurant
à l'entrée d'un cinéma et que sais-je
alors que on a bien vu que dans la vie
du quotidien chacune chacun est vacciné
de ces fameuses 11 vaccin
que l'on a quasiment à partir de la
naissance et dans la primauté de la
jeunesse et qui permettent ensuite à
chacune et à chacun de
vivre et d'être protégé et le protéger
les autres etc se croire ce qui est
important c'est qu'on puisse participer
chacun à notre façon
à la protection collective
très importante puisque en boîte ya
quand même des milliers le mort à cause
du coc bide qu'est ce qu'on en dit du
côté des sénateurs à l'est républicain
alan père
bah moi je
je suis triste mais ça fait 30 ans que
je fais de la politique on ma toujours
expliqué que la gauche était c'était lui
y est la droite dont je fais partie 7 et
les méchants je suis triste de constater
que
la gauche aujourd'hui n'a pu pour
proposition que la répression je suis
médecin et je suis sénateur donc je dis
ceci toujours le non coté praticiens du
législateur et je suis pas schizophrène
et je n'ai qu'une conscience et agir en
conscience et en responsabilité le
leitmotiv de ce gouvernement agir en
conscience et en respect ses
responsabilités c'est regarder les
chiffres regardez ce qui se passe et ne
pas imposer aux français
des mesures qui sont encore plus
discriminatoire
bien des gens on les met sous le
boisseau
je ne suis pas tout à fait le sud pas du
tout d'accord avec sceptre cette
position l'exécutif est dans une
position très complexe face à la
quatrième zone de la quatrième vague
devait arriver qu'il n'arrive pas et
puis d'un autre côté l'épidémie qui
reculent il va falloir à un moment donné
donner au français la liberté leur
liberté de vivre
alors vous êtes médecin le sénateur et
rapporteur de la proposition à bernard
jomier qui est médecin également lui
veut aller plus loin il propose un
amendement qui a beaucoup fait réagir
regardez
une sanction contraventionnelle en cas
de non respect de cette obligation à
compter du 1er janvier 2022 afin de
donner à l'ensemble des personnes
concernées le temps de s'y conformer il
est ainsi prévu que le non respect de
l'obligation vaccinale sera punie de
l'amendé forfaitaire prévue pour les
contraventions de quatrième classe à
savoir 135 euros en cas de récidive au
delà de 3 verbalisation en 30 jours
cette amende sera porté à 1500 euros
gilbert roger est ce que c'est pas un
peu
est-ce que ça va pas un peu trop loin la
vie lorsque nous avons collectivement
débattu de cette proposition de loi qui
je le rappelle supprime le pass
sanitaires pour lequel nous sommes sont
posées et contrairement à mon collègue
qui lui veut que contre eeel et les
citoyens à l'entrée de chaque espace
public on
comprend pas bien là nous sommes pas
nous non moi je ne suis pas pour la
sanction on sait très bien j'ai été
instituteur
on sait très bien qu'il y à un certain
nombre de familles qui ont du mal à
accepter la vaccination est donc il faut
des dialogues peut d'ailleurs la loi
permet même de faire l'école à la maison
donc ça ça me paraît convenable de dire
qu'il faut cette vaccination qui sera
salutaire à l'ensemble des citoyens
plutôt que
de rajouter
une amende fusse-t-elle forfaitaire
on est dans un pays de riches c'est à
dire qu'on a la chance
d'avoir
des vaccins à disposition et en même
temps on sait très bien que ce qu vite
fait des ravages
en asie en afrique
en amérique latine en regarder le brésil
qui est quand même une nation
économiquement qui était assez forte
donc il faut se protéger
collectivement
réaction à cela alain houpert cette
amende qui ce pourrait être un 6 et 135
euros si on n'est pas vaccinée qu'en
pensez vous
j'en ai vu des obligations vaccinales
le sénateur roger en a parlé on a vaincu
mais c'est la première fois que je vois
des des contraintes si importante
monsieur sûr j'étais instituteur là
c'est mettre la fessée ou français vous
savez
mon confrère guillaume barou cela dit
sans se revendiquer de la science
revient à s'auto légitimer et la science
c'est l'école du doute monsieur roger a
parlé de chiffres de pays où diable
vauvert mais un pays qu'on connaît bien
et qu'il pas loin d'ici à quatre heures
d'avion c'est israël j'ai tout le monde
tout le monde est vaccinée tout le monde
est vacciné il ya 3500 nouveaux cas pour
9 millions d'habitants en france nous
avons
4500 nouveaux cas pour près de 70
millions d'habitants c'est à dire que
dans un pays où tout le monde est motivé
il ya neuf fois plus de contaminations
qu'en france il ya quand même des
questions à se poser il faut raison
garder et je pense que la science n'a la
gauche est dans du cockpit de la raison
qui déraisonne et la droite plutôt dont
je fais partie plutôt du côté du coeur
auront le curé d'action efficace c'est
ce que vous êtes en train de vie réelle
sinon je pense que notre collègue qui
répondra à là on perd pied je vous donne
la parole je m'arrange
la vaccination est un des éléments de ce
traitement et ce n'est pas le seul et ne
mettre que la vaccination en avant
c'est pas une bonne celui la vaccination
d'alcool mais il faut raison garder et
donner la conscience faire confiance aux
français en leur propre conscience et
prendre la respect cela responsabilité
quand on est au gouvernement est venu a
obligé et à contraindre il ya des
questions à se poser le cas j'en parle
et
le personnel soignant on va en parler
mais je laisse d'abord répondre à
gilbert roger oui je voulais dire que
bien évidemment tout le monde observe ce
qui se passe et qui est
intéressant très intéressant en israël
mais israël n'a pas
de frontières étanches
temps en temps ils mènent des murs mais
c'est pas étanche et donc tous les pays
d notez qu'ils n'ont pas de vaccin il ya
des interpénétrations et c'est ce qui
permet hélas au vaccin de continuer à se
développer et moi la liberté que nous
proposons c'est pas de passes sanitaire
est en fait monsieur au pair qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent c'est qu'on fasse
semblant de dire aux gens allez vous
êtes libre mais en même temps votre
liberté elle s'arrête au moment où vous
les entrées boire un petit café sur une
terrasse entrer dans un cinéma entrer
dans une piscine vous qui êtes médecin
vous le savez très bien il ya des
maladies qui se transmettent par l'eau
et donc notamment la polio et que si on
veut bien protéger les enfants ils ont
tout intérêt quand ils vont aller à la
piscine pour apprendre à nager à être
vaccinés alors ne faisons pas des faux
semblants vous êtes dans une période où
vous sortez même des référendum en
propositions pour essayer
de deux de régler des problèmes qui vous
hante avec une partie de l'extrême
droite mais c'est tombé pendant le pape
ne tombez pas dans le panneau et fait
que cette vaccination elles permettent à
chacun d'être complètement protégé
contrainte finalement les français à
être libre si je comprends bien gilbert
roger jouret qu'on écoute quand même
patrick kanner qui s'est justifié
justement de cette vaccination
obligatoire regarder ses arguments les
adolescents souhaitant faire du sport en
club doivent désormais présenter leur
passani taire ceux qui font du sport au
collège au lycée n'en ont pas besoin la
seule solution claire et efficace la
vaccination obligatoire et universel à
la houppe rc c'est pas idiot le pass and
iter est demandé dans certains cas et
pas dans d'autres en fait il y a un
certain flou quand même sur sur ses
obligations et ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
harmoniser tout cela
ont peur de la vaccination du personnel
la vaccination où elle
vient de dire n'importe quoi en parlant
d'israël avec ses frontières qui sont
poreuses jeu j'ai cité les chiffres
il ya neuf fois plus de cas de
contamination par des tranches de dix
mille habitants en israël chez des gens
qui sont totalement vaccinés
ont été levées ta position
les gestes barrières sont utilisés ça
pose question et les chiffres que j'ai
cités tout à l'heure de 4500
contaminations en france montrent que
l'épidémie recule et jusque juste juste
jusqu'où va-t-on arriver pour dire que
l'épidémie est terminée
tout le monde sait qu'il y aura toujours
le commis 19 on sera obligé de vivre
avec donc
face à ce genre d' face à ce genre de
bêtises d'attitude
la science tout rivaux ne triomphera pas
avec de l'obligation la science c'est le
doubs nous avons affaire à du musicien
politiques qui imposent aux français le
pays de la liberté le pays de la
conscience le pays des lumières
une obligation qui est insupportable
s'il va ranger oui simplement notre
collègue se trompe en israël les gens ne
meurent plus à cause du sco vite parce
qu'ils sont vaccinés et donc une fois
vaccinés s'ils attrapent le cog hill
c'est dans une forme moindre en guyane
en nouvelle calédonie en
martinique en guadeloupe en meurent
parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
vacciner parce qu'on croit encore au
décoction de tisane
pour essayer de se protéger et on meurt
et bien
évitons que les gens meurent et moi je
reste très prudent j'ai entendu le
collègue dire qu'on était là comme it's
était derrière nous désormais non
l'aco vide elle est là
elle est présente regardez les dernières
statistiques qui se passe au brésil il
suffit qu'il ya une mutation qui
s'organise on en a une dernière pour que
ça reparte de plus belle donc protégeons
notre population soyons conscients les
uns et des autres dans se vaccinant on
se protège et
finissons avec le pass sanitaire celui
là doit disparaître alors est-ce que ça
va pas compliquer les choses auront à la
vaccination obligatoire voyez ce qu'on
dit florian philippot il a mis l'accent
sur les 1400 personnel soignant qui ont
été suspendues à cause de cette
vaccination obligatoire
vaccination que vides obligatoire 1400
soignants suspendu en ile-de-france les
hôpitaux et cliniques sous tension des
opérations des programmes et l'horreur
le régime acronis tu met sciemment en
danger de mort des français qu'en
pensez-vous alain houpert cette
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants et ses effets pervers mettre
les au plus tôt sous tension
mais j'ai une question à se poser sur
les textes on échoue à nyon qui veulent
pas se dessiner ce sont quand même des
gens ont fait dix ans d'études qui ont
sont dans la raison ce sont des gens
responsables mais monsieur monsieur
rouge a parlé tout à l'heure de chiffres
avant les chiffres du colis dont parlait
que des morts maintenant on ne parle
plus des morts on part des
contaminations moi je parle des
contaminations en iste rage par des
contaminations en france et la
vaccination la vaccination une
n'est pas seul la seule solution est
toujours raison garder sur cet homme
fragile sur cette même allez vous faire
et ce qu'il faudrait pas vaccinés et les
personnes fragiles les os brisés
d'ailleurs à se faire vacciner
puisqu'ils ne sont pas tous vaccinés
la raison c'est de proposer aux
personnes fragiles de se vacciner
et
en chine il ya une chose importante une
règle importante c'est le consentement
éclairé et quand nous sommes dans
l'obligation ça veut dire que nous
faisons fuite du consentement éclairé et
que nous faisons fi du serment que nous
avons
prêté serment sur
sur le stade a man d'hippocrate
phénomène insérer le consentement
éclairé c'est la base de la médecine
c'est la base de la relation entre le
patient et le soignant et sortons de
cette petite vie politique n vous avez
cité l'extrême droite
nous sommes des français nous sommes des
citoyens nous avons des comptes à rendre
vis-à-vis des citoyens et le premier
décompte avant c'est respecter la
liberté l'égalité et dans la fraternité
et obliger les gens et discriminant
gilbert roger réponse je voudrais aussi
vous réagissiez à ce sondage 74 % des
français en ont marre de porter le
masque et souhaiterait d'ailleurs le
remplacer par un pass annie terre au
travail qu'en pensez vous oui mais tout
ça concourt à l'idée
qu'on n'a pas de solution extrêmement
corrects avec le pass sanitaires et est
donc pour éviter toutes ces incohérences
soyons plus clair avec la vaccination
est mon collègue me fait doucement
rire et est ce que les enfoncer dans son
cabinet
parce qu'ils allaient ils avaient
atteint l'âge des vaccinations
obligatoires des onze vaccin pour
l'école il leur demandait leur avis non
et d'ailleurs quand il représentait la
piqûre comme tous les gamins comme nous
avons été nous mêmes eh ben il avait un
petit peu peur de se faire piquer donc
tout ça c'est du charabia ce qui est
important c'est d'organiser
la société pour qu'elle protège chacune
et chacun et on voit bien aujourd'hui
on a tous été moi le premier à hurler
quand y avait pas le mal quand y avait
pas de vaccins quand on voyait les gens
ne pas pouvoir aller à l'hôpital parce
que toutes les urgences étaient saturées
et qu'on ferme des lits et en même temps
aujourd'hui des vaccins il y en a
partout alors
les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés ben
oui faut les amener à le faire et moir
jamais tout à fait qu'il puisse pas être
possible pour un soignant qui lui-même
refusent la vaccination
d'entrer dans un hôpital pour soigner
des gens peuvent nous reste deux ris il
nous reste une minute la parole est à
vous alain houpert une réaction à ces
français qui veulent un pass sanitaires
au travail pour est pourquoi pour
pouvoir enlever le masque
monsieur roux j'ai reparlé d'aidés
soignants ont d'espagne en mer c'est pas
le choix niant cameco vide à l'hôpital
c'est le malade et il faut garder les
les gestes sanitaire ça c'est important
athènes a réappris aux gens déjà à se
laver les mains et j'ai dû moi je
constate que la gauche que la gauche est
dans la suite logique de la perte des
valeurs et jeu dans l'empressement de de
la gauche de vouloir imposer et de faire
appel à la répression c'est vouloir
exister politiquement jeu il faut garder
il faut garder les passes les
les gestes barrière c'est important le
pass sanitaire il ya un moment il faudra
s'en passer moi je regarde devant je
regarde l'avenir on va on va vivre avec
nos coronavirus est arrivé il sera
toujours là alors on va mettre doit pas
prendre la liberté français andré
laliberté aux français et puis le rap
rhône à ne pas se contaminer
avant merci alain houpert désolé on n'a
plus le temps malheureusement pour
débattre le malade qui apporte le virus
à l'hôpital c'était aussi l' inverse
d'ailleurs dont il est question aussi
des ehpad et des contaminations dans les
ehpad merci merci à tous les deux
d'avoir débattue ce matin sur cette
vaccination obligatoire qui est en débat
aujourd'hui au sénat merci messieurs